alexis bonjour très heureux de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
comme chaque lundi alors est la
maltraitance institutionnelle l'église
est en mesure en politique sanitaire la
crise se prolonge pour les étudiants
quelle mesure est bien ce que vous venez
de dire c'est à dire peu de mesures on
voit depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire avec les confinements
répétition les cours qui ne sont pas à
l'université mais via le numérique mal
être qui n'a fait que grandir avec
plusieurs pétitions avec aussi des
chiffres qui font peur quasiment un
étudiant sur quatre qui aurait eu des
pensées suicidaires des étudiants qui
sont plongés dans la précarité on voit
les queues de ces jeunes devant les
soupes populaires
alors certes le gouvernement a fait
quelques mesures mais qui sont loin du
compte encore les deux repas à 1 euro
pour les crous effectivement bonne
mesure mais beaucoup de croûtes étaient
encore fermés jusqu'à présent ils vont
rouvrir progressivement mais ça fait
quand même beaucoup de temps passé les
apl les aides pour le logement pour ses
plus jeunes et bien depuis 2010 est
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des modèles
macron ces 10 milliards d'euros qui ont
été économisés en baissant ses appels on
les en les jugeant en fonction des
revenus avec beaucoup d'étudiants qui
ont beaucoup perdu
là encore c'est une mesure qui est des
critiques et par le rapport de l'abbé
pierre sur le mal-logement
rien n'est fait pour aider les étudiants
qui ont du mal à se loger les étudiants
qui ont du mal à travailler pas de
petits jobs ou de jobs étudiants compte
tenu de l'activité économique réduite et
des couvre feux et bien pour eux on leur
propose de service civique c'est loin du
compte comparé aux besoins de ses
étudiants d'argent mais aussi de travail
et d'insertion alors il ya aussi
d'autres mesures pour l'insertion
professionnelle et mena le maquereau se
réjouissait de 500 mille nouveaux
apprentis en 2020 dz aussi al embauche
de 8000 euros ou 4000 euros pour ce qui
est des apprentis mais tout ce qu'il en
ressort finalement c'est encore une fois
des mesures très difficiles à voir avec
la non prise en compte finalement de la
catastrophe psychologique en cours en
france on a un psychologue sur pour
trente mille étudiants alors que
la recommandation des centres
universitaires du service universitaire
de médecine préventive par l'aide d'un
psychologue pour 1500 étudiants et tout
ce qu'on a vu depuis le début c'est
frédéric vidal avec une communication
extrêmement délétère où elle parlait des
sacrifices des étudiants en disant que
ce que vous avez donné pour le pays le
pays vous le rendra les étudiants et les
syndicats étudiants attendre encore
beaucoup plus compte tenu de la
difficulté des plus jeunes en ce moment
alors alexis des étudiants ne sont pas
les seuls à souffrir de cette gestion de
crise qu'en est il du reste de la
population
oui alors pour le reste de la population
c'est un peu jusqu'ici tout va bien
en attendant la chute le problème c'est
que l'économie et est sous perfusion est
de plus en plus de rapports arrive pour
dire que une entreprise sur deux
pourrait mettre la clé sous la porte ou
faire défaut ne pas pouvoir rembourser
ses prêts d'état d'ici la fin de l'année
donc on a des entreprises zombies
finalement qui sont aidées massivement
le chômage partiel aussi mais quand
toutes ces aides vont cesser on parle de
200 milles destructions d'emplois nettes
on voit aussi des secteurs entiers qui
sont en train de préparer les plans
sociaux les restructurations que ce soit
l'hôtellerie l'aéronautique l'automobile
là on estime par exemple que près de 40%
des bars pourrait mettre la clé sous la
porte c'est un des sénateurs et des
reins serge barbarie qui sort c'est ces
chiffres avec des contrats bien sûr
qu'ils ne vont pas être renouvelé et
encore une fois une politique
incompréhensible avec d'un côté isabelle
borne ministre qui dit aux stations de
ski fermé d'embauché pour pouvoir donner
des aides aux saisonniers
sachant que ça va être très compliqué
c'est beaucoup de 2,2 de tracasseries
administratives de difficultés aussi ce
qu'il faudrait c'est simplement relancer
l'économie on en est loin
pôle emploi se prépare à une déferlante
de chômage alors ils ont recruté
plusieurs conseillers et ellie et des
chiffres évoqués ce serait 600 mille
sept cent mille emplois qui pourraient
partir et le taux de chômage est reparti
à la hausse à partir du troisième
trimestre
2020 et ça ne pourrait faire qu'empirer
et qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre dans
cet entre deux de couvre-feu et
d'activité réduite bien tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est une hypocrisie
une hypocrisie au sommet de l'état pour
ne pas appeler finalement un confinement
de fait confinement mais ce couvre-feu à
18 heures qui est un prétexte pour
finalement mettre des amendes tout à
fait honteuse aux automobilistes coincés
dans les bouchons on apprend ce week-end
que tous les passagers d'une automobile
écoperont de 135 euros damende s'ils
sont sur la route après 18 heures
comment est ce possible de traiter les
gens de cette façon est derrière plus
personne
finalement ne comprends ces mesures
sanitaires qui n'en sont pas que sont le
couvre feu les confinements et dont
l'épreuve reste à faire encore une fois
beaucoup de débats par rapport à la
réalité concrète pour limiter la
propagation de virus de ces mesures la
vérité qu'on ne veut pas voir
aujourd'hui c'est le ravage qui a été
fait par ces mesures sur l'économie
on a l'impression finalement d'un d'une
hypocrisie globale où plus rien n'est
sûr la campagne de vaccination s'est
beaucoup de si si les labos livre ch'ti
tout est fait alors la campagne sera un
succès mais on attend de voir quelle
sera la réponse des labos à propos de la
et puis la campagne de santé publique
des volumes la con qui se résume à
quelques images d'influenceurs sur
instagram
donc après ce qu'on a vu en 2020 qui
ressemblait à une déroute l'état qui
dépense 10 millions plus de 10 millions
pour les cabinets de conseils pour faire
le travail finalement d administration
on est en train de vivre peut-être la
débâcle de 2021
merci beaucoup avec si alexis poulain on
vous retrouve tous les lundis matin dans
la matinale de rtl je le rappelle pour
votre édito